so something kind of terrifyingly ironic
happened on the way to this movie I
start up the car and rain just plummets
against my windshield like instantly
this is not I'm not joking this really
habit I'm just sitting there in a car
like this this doesn't this doesn't bode
well this is I'm scared Noah is directed
by Darren Aronofsky and stars Russell
Crowe as Noah the title character now a
lot of people have been very up in arms
about this movie see paramount screen
three versions of this movie without
Aronofsky's permission to various
religious groups and people were just
like this is not right
we hate it this is horrible controversy
controversy controversy
Aronofsky was understandably upset about
that because he didn't even know they
were gonna do those screenings he had
his own idea what the film was gonna be
like and eventually paramount decided
you know what we're just gonna release
Darren Aronofsky's original vision so I
don't really see what the point of all
that rigmarole was because what we have
in theaters is his movie now I would
like in this movie to Titanic and not
necessarily in plot in the way it's made
but the fact that it is a movie you go
into it and you have an idea of what's
gonna go down there's gonna be some rain
there's gonna be a flood people are
gonna die and more than likely Noah's
gonna win but it's the different things
that Aronofsky did along the way that
made this a very enjoyable movie to
watch this movie definitely had a lot of
impressive things about it the special
effects mostly were very good there were
some stuff with animals that looked a
little bit questionable but for the most
part the special effects were very
convincing especially the rain and the
flood stuff that stuff was all done
extremely well now there is an aspect of
this movie that I know will anger people
largely people who are religious purists
this is very much so an adaptation of
things that are in the Bible and he
definitely twists a lot of it in
creative ways and if that angers you as
a person then this is not a movie you're
gonna want to watch because you will
watch this movie and be like that didn't
happen that didn't happen that didn't
happen what's that all about I don't
understand that what this is is a very
interesting drama filled and tension
filled adaptation of that original story
and I was very much so entertained by
this movie for a large part of it the
movie starts a little bit Rocky
figuratively and literally but once it
finds its footing I was very in thrall
with Noah he really sold the look of
what he was going for and he also has a
lot of signature things that dare
Aronofsky doesn't his films with his
editing style and especially the score
the score is fantastic Russell Crowe is
perfect in this movie I thought he did a
really great job as this character you
really felt as if he was this man who
just had this incredible amount of
devotion that he didn't want to wave her
in any way despite how difficult the
task may be and he definitely sold his
performance I thought he was great in
the movie Ray Winstone was also really
good in this film very intimidating very
villainous most of the cast did a great
job Jennifer Connelly was good Emma
Watson was actually really good this is
one of her better performances there are
parts to this movie that aren't great
though and a lot of it is getting to
that arc part where he builds the art
and then the eventual flood and
everything up until then you really like
where is this movie going like it seems
to waver a lot there's some aspects to
this movie that are not in any of the
trailers that aren't really publicized
and I think for a reason because parts
of this movie do come off kind of like
Lord of the Rings but you know what
that's because this is an adaptation by
someone else who read that and said this
is how I want to see it and he doesn't
disrespect the source material he
doesn't disrespect the characters and he
really presents a very interesting view
of how this may take place once they
start building the ark I thought the
movie really understood where it was
going from there on and it was very
entertaining and very suspenseful from
then on out but up until then it was a
little bit rocky so I can't say this is
a great movie I thought the performances
were great I thought it was a good
looking movie despite some usage of
shaky-cam that I didn't really feel look
that great but the script was
interesting the way they decided to tell
some of the characters stories was cool
and I love Russell Crowe in the movie I
thought he was fantastic
I'm gonna give Noah a B+ I do think it
will anger some people I think that it
will cause controversy even more so than
it already has
hello ever as a film I think it is very
well made I think the performances in it
are also very good so if you guys saw
the movie let me know what you thought
of it below and as always thank you so
much for watching and if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]
so guys if you may have noticed lately
I'm trying to find ways to give back to
you
I've been running various promotions
that allow you guys to do awesome free
stuff and I have a new one to tell you
guys about if you ever heard of hulu
hulu plus is a way that you can watch a
lot of really cool entertainment movies
television shows ad-free a lot of great
stuff is on there like SNL and Jimmy
Kimmel the TV shows lost and there's a
ton of really cool movies I myself have
a subscription to it and I look through
it quite often find quite a bit of stuff
to binge watch and that's something that
I really enjoyed doing Hulu has granted
me the permission to give you guys two
weeks free through Hulu I am able to
give you guys two weeks for free if you
want to do anything you want to on Hulu
for two weeks it is free of charge go to
Hulu Plus calm slash Chris stuckman
that's Hulu Plus calm slash crisp
stuckman and you can watch anything you
want TV shows movies there's tons of
great entertainment there and I want to
give back to you guys you guys have
given me so much and I want to find a
way that you guys can experience some
cool free entertainment and through Hulu
I'm running this promotion now I'm gonna
be running it for a while and I hope you
guys check it out and stick around on
Hulu Plus because they like what I'm
doing here and then want to share with
you guys and I want to share it too so
go to Hulu Plus comm slash Chris Duckman
and have two weeks free to watch awesome
entertainment I hope you guys stick
around even after those two weeks are up
because it's pretty great thanks guys